this is the post with Paul and Troy so
just so I have this right Paul is the
real one
Troy is the clone I have to say two
things first of all he's the kid buu of
musically stars he's cloned himself he
took one out this guy how old
first of all I want to see how old he
actually is Paul Zimmer he he is kid buu
down to lying about the age part the
other thing exactly the other thing is I
feel like he took a page out of like
Venezuelan baseball players like when
they when they come to America and
they're like yeah I'm only 18 and
they're like 30 just cracking [ __ ]
crazy crazy homerun numbers and you're
like are you you're you said you're
eight teams like yeah I'm 18 and I'm 18
you gotta respect that man age is just a
number they're just trying to get a
fresh start you know
dude he's Paul simmers 24 and this Troy
Becker kid is supposed to be 14 dog this
is fully done puberty dude like twice by
now and you're gonna try and revert back
to a 14 year old this is I mean we'll
just get into the Troy Becker Instagram
after but you hit that second post
yeah you mean the you mean the video or
this in the video you can see my screen
share right yeah looking at it yeah no
not that one I mean on Paul Zimmer's
Instagram Oh copy copy alright so yeah
we're still like this this is [ __ ] man
it's [ __ ] up dude okay no no I meant
the second from the first one yeah oh
boy here we go
I'm telling his second post promoting
this new identity he has hey what's up
my name is Troy Becker I'm an actor
Paul Zimmer reached out to me and asked
to record a video because he says he
really really looks like me and he
wanted to post it on to something called
tick tock so there you go Paul Zimmer
nice to meet you guys hey dude well
first up what the [ __ ] with his hair
what is that a wig is that a wig why is
that why is the hairline
I want the hairline like down here loot
it down to his his head maybe he's
[ __ ] like 50 and he's actually bald
he really has no idea what tick tock is
he's a 60 year old man doesn't know what
tick tock is I know that's the kid right
now is like I don't know something
called tick-tock Amish Amish kids know
they probably even know what that is
[Laughter]
it gets [ __ ] weirder man so they go
to the third post hey it's Paul Zimmer
this is probably gonna this is probably
gonna be my last social post ever I must
say that I am very grateful for social
media and I have had such a fun time
using all these different social
platforms and having the opportunity to
entertain millions of people for many
years with this being said I have come
to a place in my life where being in the
spotlight and being an entertainer is no
longer my passion although it deeply
saddens me to leave so bluntly
especially that so many of you have
watched me for so many years dude how
long was this kid I'm [ __ ] musically
for dude he this is like it was around
for like eight months
dude this [ __ ] is like an Academy Award
level man it's he talks like he's Morgan
Freeman I know I didn't want to leave my
social media pages just sitting to die
dot dot dot so I have decided to give my
social media accounts to Troy Becker IG
because he is one of the dopest people I
know and he is literally my younger twin
my much younger twin I believe Troy is
15 or 16 years old hahaha
I know that Troy Becker IG is busy
filming his TV show and a movie but I
hope he spent some time on here to bring
joy to y'all thank you all so much for
supporting me I am sending all of my
love to each and every one of you each
and every one of you everybody give it
cuz I'm in the stream chair I just got
to give it a quick look to camera hold
on do it hit him with hit him with it
did you do it did you do it okay good
now I'm genuine this is this is [ __ ]
this is a bizarre man alright so now
next pose okay wait still still on Paul
Zimmer next post still on Paul Zimmer
next post this is this is [ __ ] up dude
what kind of weird hey it's Roy Becker
who we don't know who's that youtubers
everyone thought was kidnapped marina
Joyce yeah yeah yeah marina Joyce yeah
yeah him and marina Joyce are part of
some larger conspiracy where they got
like lobotomized and you know you know
not that I brush pants are super tight
bro yeah I know well there's just too
much [ __ ] detail there hey it's Troy
oh now it's Troy that's the 15 year old
yeah you rezone so you're looking at
child porn that's what you're looking at
right nine now yeah exactly
hey it's Troy Becker it feels weird
posting this on here haha it's sweating
emoji that's how I read those emojis as
you all know from Paul Zimmer's last
post he no longer uses social media and
decided to give me the social media
account because we've become great
friends and we look quite similar I must
admit my Instagram is Troy Becker IG
Paul has asked me to also post on here
and to spread love and joy
I am honored to have this opportunity to
reach so many amazing people want to
thank you I have so many big things
coming my TV and a movie show I am
hang on but I will make time to spread
love all over social media for you bro
he's gonna be a cult leader like give
him a couple years bro it's so scary
legitimately
this is wild it what if this is a big
joke it was like what if it's a bit
hairline again dude
what is going on that's the next most
the hey it's Troy Becker IG wishing all
a Merry Christmas and then in
parentheses still feels so weird posting
on this account haha I just want to
still make it clear that it's this is
weird to Stefan I'm not playing it down
absolutely not my account and I'm Troy
Becker and I'm not Paul Zimmer at all
and it's and this is Troy Becker here
I'm 15 I'm an actor all I say is this
dude okay hairline here very normal
hairline here
oh he's combing it across the front
that's what he's doing
yeah alright he's he's stapling his
bangs to his forehead alright so now
let's go to the Troy Becker IG yep love
this action shot right here up he loves
sports did you know we go to the very
first the very first post his first one
ever and read that caption blessed to be
filming my TV show the best part about
all of this
Troy Becker [ __ ] is that he keeps going
on about his TV showing his movie that
he's filming right and then he'll post
clips of him of like from the TV show or
or the movie or whatever and he'll say
this scene with crying emojis like this
scene killed me and it's just someone
filming him some other random person
with a DSLR not even mics or anything in
the audio associate off like it's a real
[ __ ] TV show dude alright you know
you know what creeps me out about this
and this is just
can I ask you something all this audio
is [ __ ] you get a [ __ ] laugh mic at
least if you're trying to play this off
like it's a real movie also this lens is
soft as [ __ ] do it I don't get a sharper
lens only can I ask you something this
is just filmed iPhone portrait mode fake
I noticed that 95% of the time that
we've been hanging out you're on your
phone and you you always look so anxious
you're not even there when we're hanging
out
Becky told me that Becky Dave his nailed
the sorry go ahead
no he nailed the what no the what well
he nailed the you know teen drama you
know this is what they care about
hanging out and being on their phones
and you know when those two worlds
collide sometimes it can lead to a
little bit of tension and as you know as
Paul as our sorry Troy has found out
here
Becky might be more interested in her
phone than she is their connection I
loved I love the mat bars on a 16:9 shot
yeah just completely cropping out the
top of his head and framing out his hand
this feels very TV as far as I'm
concerned exactly I mean that was
definitely a stylistic choice by the DP
for sure sorry his short film yeah all
right all right let's live this right
out man I can't wait til I run into him
you know in an audition room and you're
like oh oh Troy Troy what's up dude and
he's like yeah because I'm 15 this role
is gonna be hard for the production
because I can only be on set for about
four hours so technically a miner this
time so I'm just wondering is there
something about this month or
what's up [ __ ] my light died right
Becky you can talk to him you know that
right this [ __ ] empty hollow eyeballs
you can talk into that [ __ ] it's wild
bro he looks dead inside what the [ __ ]
like like this picture there looks like
zero happiness in his [ __ ] head well
he's trying to play off this he's trying
to produce his like bullish innocent
look I think right yes to read the
caption for that picture to I love
seeing people smile it always makes me
smile - dude that's not a smile at all
[Laughter]
you